If I prove to you the prophet Muhammad
is the final prophet and the Quran is
the final message, would you accept
Islam?
>> Yeah, I would.
>> Okay. So, what I would say is this.
This is one video. If you care about the
dunya more than skip it by one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who have been
fed through the emergency food aid. You
are going to be sponsoring 4,200
orphans. You will be helping 250,000
people in Gaza. You'll be helping
123,000 people to be fed through our
Kmani program. You will help feed
551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 massages that are going to be built
around the world and 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
one um 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund so that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them is far more important than the
dunya. And you will see every penny that
you give on your Makyama. The decision
is yours. The link is there. Donate now.
>> Yeah. It will teach you how to pray
salah. Yeah. So, um once you take a
shahada, you can use this to learn how
to pray salah. Thank you.
>> No problem. Okay. So, you had a
question.
>> Um I have a question. So, I'm an
Orthodox Christian, Romanian.
>> Yes.
>> Although obviously the Quran does
interest me and I believe that it can it
can be the truth. Although I do have a
question. Is it true that Jesus was like
obviously in the Bible Jesus never says
who his God is? Could it be a
possibility that Allah could be like
connected to Jesus. Oh, no.
>> 100%. So, what I'll say is this. So,
>> yeah. So, so yeah, you might No, it's
fine. It's fine. It's fine. No, you
don't. It's fine. You're a Catholic.
>> Um, no. Or Orthodox Christian.
>> Oh, Orthodox Christian. Okay.
>> Western or Eastern.
>> Um, Romanian.
>> Uh, yeah. So, Eastern Eastern
Orthodox.
>> Yeah. So, what we believe? We believe in
Jesus. So, as Muslims, I believe in
Jesus.
>> I believe in Jesus's mother, Mary.
>> In the Quran, there's a whole chapter
called Mary. Okay. So, we have to
believe in Mary.
>> We believe in Jesus. We believe for
example he had a miraculous she had a
miraculous birth. Yes. Now the Jews what
the Jews believe is that they insult
Jesus and Mary. So they believe we don't
believe this. They believe that Mary had
intimacy outside of marriage and that
Jesus was born. Yeah. So they cursed
Jesus and they cursed um Mary. As
Muslims what the Christians done is they
went to the other extreme. So the
Christians came and said okay the Jews
cursed Jesus. We say Jesus is God. So
you got two extremes. Jews who degrade
Jesus. Christians who elevate him to a
level of God. Muslims come in the middle
and say, "Hold on a second. We don't
insult him. We believe in him. He is a
prophet of God. We believe in Mary.
Jesus had a miraculous birth. We believe
Jesus is the Messiah. We believe in that
Jesus worshiped the one true God. We
don't
>> second coming
>> and and his second coming as well. And
we believe that Jesus is not God. So
what they what Christians believe is
that Jesus is God. Do you believe Jesus
is God?"
No, I believe Jesus is a picture of a
representation of him.
>> Okay. So, when you mean representation,
you mean he was sent by God?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Good. So, we believe that as well.
>> So, what we say is the following. If you
look into the Bible, John chapter uh
what was it? 3:17.
>> 17:3. Yes.
>> Yes. John 17:3, Jesus is saying that so
they may know you and have eternal life,
the only true God and Jesus whom you
sent. If Jesus is God, why is he saying
the one true God is the father?
He can't be God.
>> So Jesus is saying what the father is
the one true God. Now we don't call God
father. We call him Allah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. So what we're saying is this to
start. We believe in Jesus. We believe
in his miracles. We believe in Mary. We
say God cannot be a man. Do you believe
God can be a man like me?
>> I believe God is a man.
>> Okay. Do you believe God can be a man
like me?
>> I sleep. Okay. Look, I sleep. Can God
sleep?
>> No.
>> Does God need to sleep?
>> Good. I get hungry. Would God get
hungry? No.
>> Okay. I can die. Can God die?
>> No.
>> Good. So, God cannot be a man.
>> Mhm.
>> Good. So, we say Jesus was sent by God.
Like in if you look into the book of
Acts in the Bible, chapter 2, verse 22,
it says Jesus of Nazareth, a man. He's a
man chosen by who? Chosen by God and
with wonders, miracles, and signs that
God did through him. And you're a
witness to it. So, nowhere in the entire
Bible Jesus ever says, "I am God or
worship me." In the contrary, he always
says, "The one true God is the father. I
myself cannot do nothing. As I see, I
judge and my judgment is just. For I
don't seek my will but the will of my
father." Why is Jesus keeping up the
father, the father, the father, the
father? If he is God, he would say it's
me. So you can see clearly that. So you
can see clearly that the one true God is
the father. So we believe we call him
Allah. So that's why we believe that
Jesus is a man. He was a prophet and he
was sent by God.
>> Oh, you know that he prayed like Muslims
do? I didn't know that.
>> If you go to the chapter of Luke 22
around verse 38, he he went in the
garden of God's enemy. Yeah.
>> He went on his knees and he prostrated.
They said, "Father, take this cup away
from me that your will be done, not
mine."
>> So Christians before at the beginning
they used to pray like that. They used
to prostrate and uh like we Muslims do.
But then with the time they change, they
changed it. Since you are Eastern
Orthodox, some Eastern Orthodox they
still do it. They still prostrate like
Muslims do.
>> Although would you consider it
disgraceful if you are to convert?
>> No. What you mean? No. No. Do you mean
do you mean as converted Christians or
you convert to Islam? No. Convert to
Islam?
>> No. To us, the reason we call you revert
like she accept Islam. You're a revert.
You're coming back to your original
place. We believe you guys, we were all
born Muslims. It's just that your family
were Christians that made you Christian.
Yeah. So what we say is that sister when
you come to Islam you're coming back to
your origins. You're coming to your
actual family. Imagine imagine imagine
you have your mother and father. You was
adopted by some people and then you find
out they your mother and father and you
come back to your mother and father.
They your real mother and father. Do you
get what I'm trying to say? So in that
instance if you believe like you believe
God is one.
>> Yeah.
>> He's not a man or a woman. He doesn't
have a mother and father. He doesn't
have children.
>> Good. Do you believe that he's not a
statue?
>> No.
>> Good. All right. So you believe we call
him Allah. Okay. So would you accept
that God is the all knowing?
>> So just one thing, just one thing. By
the way, Jesus called God Allah. You
know in Aramaic
>> the the language of Jesus,
>> Allah is God. But uh since it's been
like uh in in in Arabic same in Aramaic
>> is Allah is is Allah. Jesus used to call
him Allah.
>> Yeah. Even even uh uh Arab Christians
they call uh God Allah. So Jesus even
said that. So you believe God is what?
Good. Do you believe what do you believe
about the prophet Muhammad?
>> Um
>> do you know anything about him?
>> Yeah, I do. Um I do know that he had
three people come to him. No, I think
that's a different prophet.
>> No, tell me.
>> I forgot the names. No, it's fine. I
know about Prophet Muhammad.
>> Okay. What do you think of him? Is he do
you do Do you believe he's a prophet?
What do you believe he is?
>> Um
>> the messenger of point.
>> Yeah.
>> No, no, but do do you believe that or do
you want me to prove it?
>> I mean, you can prove it to me. Yeah.
>> Okay. Right. So, we say the following,
sister. Yeah. So, if I prove to you the
prophet Muhammad is the final prophet
and if I prove the Quran is a word of
God, would you accept Islam?
>> Sorry.
>> If I prove to you the prophet Muhammad
is the final prophet and the Quran is
the final message, would you accept
Islam?
>> No, I would.
>> Okay. So, what I would say is this.
Let's might take a couple of minutes
here. Okay. So now the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he was known by his
enemies to be the truthful. So his
enemies before Islam came they knew him
to be the truthful person. They used to
leave their belongings with him gold and
money. He used to look after it. Yeah.
Because he was known to be a truthful
person. So we are free options. So we're
looking at the psychology. There's three
options for prophet Muhammad. Either he
was a liar, either he was a deluded
person or he was saying the truth. Okay
let's assess them one by one. Now when a
person lies why do they lie? What's the
reason for lying? to avoid the truth.
>> Avoid the truth. And also sometimes
people lie to gain something. Yeah.
>> Good. Now the prophet Muhammad came and
he was preaching the oneness of God. In
pagan Arabia they used to have idols 360
idols that were made with their own
hands. So imagine they were worshiping
something that they made with their own
hands. So the prophet Muhammad came and
said listen these are all man-made.
Worship the one true God. Why are you
worshiping something you made with your
own hands? Yes. Allah says in the Quran
an idol if you like they used to put
food in front of the idols. Yeah. If a
fly, Allah says in the Quran, if a fly
was to come and eat that food, the idol
can't even protect the food against the
fly. So why are you worshiping the
statue? So now when the prophet Muhammad
came and was preaching about the oneness
of God to worship Allah alone, they
tried to persecute him. Now they said to
him the following. If he's a liar, he
would have taken this. They said to him,
if you want money, we'll give you money.
If you want woman, we'll give you woman.
If you want status, we'll give you
status. Stop preaching about Allah. If
he's a liar, would you not take that and
say, okay, you know what? I was doing it
for the money and the fame, and I want
to take it. Right.
>> Yeah. Right?
>> Do you know what he said? He said, "If
you was to give the sun on my left hand
and the moon on my right hand, I will
never stop preaching what I'm
preaching." Does that sound like a liar?
>> No.
>> No. Because it means he's true to his
cause. He's saying, "Listen, forget the
money and the car. I mean, all that kind
of stuff. If you was to give me
universes or the planets, I'm not going
to stop preaching what I'm preaching.
So, he can't be a liar." Good. Now, you
might come and say he's maybe deluded.
Now, we have a story and the s is the
life of the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. His son Ibrahim died. He had a
son. He's died. When he died, the moon
eclipsed. There was an eclipse. So some
of his companions run to him and said,
"Oh, oh, messenger of God, this shows
that you're a true prophet because your
son died and the moon eclipse." Now, if
he's deluded, would he not use that to
his opportunity and say, "Yeah, you see
guys, I am a true prophet." Would he not
say that?
>> Like like you know when the moon eclipse
and his son died,
>> if he's deluded, he would use I'll give
you an example. If I said I'm a prophet
of God and I said I can do miracles and
all of a sudden you saw it's night time
the sun goes up. I say see I told you it
might have got nothing to do with me but
I would use that opportunity but see you
see it was night. You see I went son.
See I'm a true prophet. That's me lying
and I'm deluded.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So when the prophet Muhammad's son
died and the moon eclipse they said the
reason the moon eclipse is because your
son died which means you're a true
prophet. He would have affirmed that and
say yes. Do you know what he said? He
said no. He said the moon don't eclipse
when nobody's deaf. So if he was
deluded, he would have taken an
opportunity for that. He rather denied
it and said no, the moon don't eclipse.
So he can't be deluded. The only option
is is that he's a truthful person. Now
how is he truthful? He was standing on a
mountain one day and he told the pagan
Arabs. Yeah. Who who didn't like him? He
didn't like him. They said he said to
them, "If I was to tell you there is an
army behind this mountain coming to kill
us all, would you believe me?" They
said, "Of course we'll believe you." He
said, "Okay." He said, "We believe you
because you're a truthful person." He
said, "Okay, I'm telling you I'm the
prophet of God." They said, "No, you're
a liar." So, it shows that he was a
truthful person. He did not lie and he's
not deluded. So, when it comes to his
message, sister, the Quran is the only
scripture that hasn't been changed. The
Bible has been changed and altered. Like
you, I don't know how many books you
have as Eastern Orthodoxes.
>> Uh, 73.
>> You have 73. The Protestants have 66.
The Catholics have 82 or 83, something
along those lines.
>> No, Catholics 73.
>> 73. So what I'm saying is the Quran is
the only scripture that has been
preserved, hasn't been changed. Yeah. So
what we're saying is that the Quran has
miracles in it. I came to Islam 13 years
ago. I studied different religions for
about 3 and a half years. The prophet
Muhammad has made prophecies that has
come to like to be today. I'll give you
one example. You know where's the
tallest building today?
>> In Dubai. Yeah. Okay. Good. The prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said 1400
years ago a time the day of judgment
will not come until barefooted bedins
Arab bedins will race with one another
to build tall buildings. He said this
1400 years ago. Now who's he talking
about? He said barefooted bedins. Who
are these people? Do you know Muhammad
the the the ruler in Dubai?
>> Khalifa.
>> Yeah. You know you know him. You know
there's a picture of him and his dad
about 45 50 years ago.
>> The really famous one. You know the one
who's the ruler of Dubai?
>> Yeah. Him. You know there's a picture of
him and his father
>> and they they are not wearing any
they're not wearing any shoes. They're
put barefoot.
>> There's a picture of them. You can find
it on Google. So the prophet Muhammad
said barefooted bedings they were
bedwins like camel herders. Yeah. He
said the time will come they will race
with one another to build tall
buildings. How did he know this? Because
now the tallest building is where 50
years ago they didn't even have socks
on. The same king ruler who's a
trillionaire today. How did the prophet
Muhammad know this miracle?
>> Also he like predicted.
>> Yes. prophecies and there's there's many
I can give you. I just want to hold you
guys here to it's cold as well. Yeah.
There are many I can give you 20 25 so
many miracles the prophecies that he
said. You get it? Like he said a a time
will come where women will be dressed by
naked. How can you be dressed by naked?
Well, you see sometimes you have women
who are
>> well the clothes that they wear is so
tight. It's as if they're naked. But
that's interesting cuz I would never
think how could you be clothed but
naked. It's like an oxymoron. But now
you think okay the way women are dressed
it's like you're clothed but you're
actually naked cuz everyone can. Do you
get what I'm trying to say? So yes,
there's so many things that the prophet
Muhammad prophesized and it's all come
to be. So we say it is impossible for
him to know except it's from God
Almighty, you know, and the Quran is
preserved. It hasn't it hasn't changed
and there's many miracles in it.
>> I have another question. So if you if I
was to revert to a Muslim
>> Yes. Islam. Yeah.
>> Sorry.
>> That's fine.
>> Um if I was to rev to a Muslim, would I
have to wear a hijab?
>> No. It's not a must.
>> It's it's it's not option. It is it is
something that is obliged for a woman to
wear. However, what we say is that you
not doing it doesn't take out the fault
of Islam. For example, me shaving my
beard is haram. But I can still be a
Muslim, but I'm sinning. So what it is
is that gradual steps. Nobody's saying
overnight start wearing a do you get
what I'm trying to say? So what we're
saying is don't worry, he's here for
security. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He's got
your back. Yes. He's got it obligation.
However, however,
>> you don't you know what we say, don't
run before learning how to walk.
>> That comes that's between you and Allah
subhana wa tala and that would come with
the time. You understand? Maybe in the
future we would see oh I want to wear
>> but that's your own choice and your own
>> but the best of thing is your salvation
from the hellfire. That's what is
important. So if I was to read it, do
you believe that I would be brought
peace among you?
>> Yes. Yeah. Yeah. 100%. Look, let me put
it like this, sister. When you become a
Muslim, we believe all your previous
sins are forgiven. You're like a born
baby. It's like your freshest.
>> Yes. And not only that, for example, all
your sins are turned into good deeds.
Yeah. So now you need to understand that
obviously if I came to Islam 13 years
ago, you will be tested. Allah says in
the Quran, don't say that you're going
to say I'm a Muslim and not be tested.
Those tests are going to make you who
you are. I've been through a lot of
tests. I'll tell you, I've been through
ups and downs. But let me tell you
something. When I look back, I thank God
for putting me through this test because
it made me who I am. And the prayers
that I ask for, I've asked for specific
prayers and all of them come true. And
why? But God tests you. Cuz you know
when you make a prayer, God God prepares
you for that prayer. Cuz if you want
something, whatever it is, argument
sake, I don't know,
>> you want um a a business or this or or
or a good man good man in your life, a
husband or whatever it is. Yeah. With
God Almighty, all things are possible.
It's like imagine you go to a king who
owns the earth and he says to you, "What
do you want from me?" And you go, "Oh,
can you give me an apple?" He's going to
get offended. He's going to say, "Man, I
own everything and you want an apple
from me. Are you mocking me?" When you
go to God Almighty, with Allah, all
things are possible. Ask him whatever
you want. Be specific. That's your Lord.
That's who's created you. And that's the
reason why, if you think about it,
sister, for example, your mother gave
birth to you, looked after you to this
age. Yeah. And you show gratitude to
her. And Allah says that be grateful be
with your parents. Obviously, if they
tell you to leave Islam, you don't
follow them respectfully. Like my dad
hated Islam. My dad kicked me at my
house. My dad slapped me when I became a
Muslim cuz my dad hates Islam. But I
always have respect for him. When he
comes to my house, I kiss his head. Even
though when he insults me. Sometimes he
insults me, cursing me. Yeah. He says to
me, "Come." Once he was watching TV, he
saw Bin Ladden. He said, "Come. Your
friends on TV." I was like, "Who's he
talking about?" So he mocks me
sometimes. But the thing is, my job is
to have duty towards him and be
respectful towards him. So when you have
that relationship with God Almighty
sister, today your heart is beating. Do
you tell your heart to beat?
>> Good. You're breathing when you sleep.
Do you say, "Hey, lungs, carry on
breathing." Yeah. Or I'm gonna die.
>> No. Did you eat food today?
>> Yes.
>> Did you eat a drink?
>> Yes. No. No alcohol. Yeah, I'm joking.
No.
>> Okay, good. You slept?
>> Yes.
>> Good. Who is giving you all of this?
>> Good. God has given you heart. He's
given you life. If I gave you 10 billion
pounds, but I said to you, what's your
name, sister?
>> Marina.
>> Sister Bruno. If I said to you,
>> Marina. Mar. Sorry. Marina. Sister
Marina. If I said to you, I'm going to
give you 10 billion pounds, but tomorrow
you're going to die. Would you take it?
>> No. Good. Who gives you life every day?
God. Good. So that means 10 billion
pounds is not worth your life. Who gives
you life every day? God. Who makes your
heartbeat every day? God. Who makes your
stomach the food that you eat? Do you
have to tell your stomach, "Hey, listen,
make it nutritional and make it good for
me." Allah has created your kidney, your
liver. There are trillions of cells in
your body that make you stand up. Look
at the blessing of your eye. Look at the
blessing of the food. Imagine if we ate
food and it was painful.
>> We enjoy food, right?
>> Yes. There's pleasures that God Almighty
has given to us and he's telling the
following. This life is like a taster.
All the pleasures that we have like for
example when you get married you have
intimacy when you have food when you
sleep. All of these things are God
saying to you here's a little taster but
in paradise you're going to have the
best of the best. So all God is saying
is put me first and I will give you the
world and the hereafter.
>> You know you asked something you you
asked about peace. Yeah.
peace. You'll find it here in this book
that you have got
>> and I will find peace in that book.
>> Would you be able to invite me right
now?
>> Yes. Yes, sister. Like like I said,
alhamdulillah. And and and before we do
that, I'll say to you, sister, let me
tell you something. Yeah. Like even with
me. Yeah. You know, before this very
place, you know, I used to come clubbing
and partying here 16 I think 17 years
ago. I used to come clubbing and
partying here. There was a penthouse up
there. Yeah. Every week I used to come
here and I used to chase the world, the
money, the girls, the house, etc. All
this kind of stuff. Yeah. Never brought
me happiness. You know why? Because you
need to understand something. Our body,
our flesh is temporary. We're going to
die.
>> The soul is eternal. The soul will only
be happy and content with that is
eternal. And
that's the reason why I never find
happiness. Be it the girls, the
clubbing, the partying, the holidays, it
never brought me happiness. You know
why? Cuz it was temporary. I was keep
giving the soul the wrong type of food.
So if you give the soul the real food,
which is what? The remembrance of God,
you would have peace. Let me tell you
something. If they took everything from
me, wall, I swear upon God. If they took
everything but not Islam, I'll be the
most happiest person. When you have
peace, I know why I'm here. I know my
destination. I know where I'm going. I
don't need to follow this pressure, that
pressure. And there's so much pressure
of you women as well, how to look, the
beauty industry, look like this, dress
like this, and they sexually objectify
you. In Islam, we say a woman is
honorable. Do you get it? If you like,
if you say to me, "Shake my hand, I
won't touch you because I have respect
for you." Do you get it? I believe that
for example, when you get married, a
Muslim man, for example, you're right.
You are the prize. You're not red pill.
They say, "Oh, the man is a price." No,
it's not. In Islam, the woman is a
price. As a woman, you have a right to
ask for dowry. So, when you get married
to a Muslim man, he has to pay you a
diary. So, that can be gold, that can be
car, that can be money, whatever. It's
up to you. Number two, there's no 50/50
in Islam. He has to provide for
everything in the house. Electric, gas,
bill, rent, petrol, everything for the
car, clothes, and your money is your
money. He's not allowed to touch your
money. Yes. And she's surprised. She's
like, you know what? I should have
become a Muslim a long time ago. She's
like, wait. She's like, I'm going to
accept Islam now. She's like, you know
what? I don't know what you
>> in Christianity you must obey your
husband.
>> Yes. But you see these rights as well
that's given. It's not given in
Christianity.
>> In Christianity it says it says the the
man is the head of the house
>> and the head of the man is Christ.
>> Church and the head of Christ is God.
You know this this is by Paul. But even
here you see
>> Jesus is not God because he's got a
head. And only that you know in
Christianity you know they believe that
Eve was the one who tempted Adam to eat
from the tree. So all the evil is from
>> so so you know what that means you know
when you give birth they say the pain
that you're going through is because of
Eve. We don't believe that.
>> Yeah. So we we don't believe that. We're
like why would you suffer a pain? That's
something you've done.
>> So the original we don't believe in the
original
>> in Islam. In Islam when a woman is in
pain she's in jihad means struggle you
reward. Not the other jihad talking
about
>> and you get a reward for the pain.
>> Yeah. And not only that, if you die, you
a martyr. In Christianity, you are told
you're suffering because of what you've
done. How is that fair? In in in
Christianity, for example, if a man
rapes a woman, he all he has to do is
pay 50 shekels to the father and keep
her. Imagine you're being told to marry
a rapist.
>> Not only not only that, he can never
divorce
him.
>> You're not allowed to divorce. In Islam,
you have a right to divorce.
>> Yes. And not only that, in Islam, a
woman, a man that rapes a woman, he gets
he gets punished punishment. Yeah. So
there's so many rights. Anyways, I don't
want to hold shahada. Is anyone forcing
you to accept Islam?
>> It's your own will. Yeah. Okay. So you
can repeat after me.
>> Yeah.
>> Allahill
>> repeat English. I bear witness
>> I bear witness.
>> There is nothing
>> worthy of worship.
Worship worship except Allah except
Allah and the prophet Muhammad and the
prophet Muhammad
>> peace be upon him peace be upon him is
his final messenger and Jesus Christ is
I'll be honest with you I wasn't
expecting that subhan allah may Allah
bless you sister I'm going to we're
going to have to give you a mat as well
now
[laughter]
I want my mom good good
>> I was going to ask a question if I was
to go to like the I
is even if my family aren't Muslim,
could they come?
Could I do it with
>> I know that women and men pray separate,
but if I would want like my father and
my mother there while I take
>> No, you can they can they can like it
might be like in a place of the mosque
cuz men come and pray, they will take
you to a certain place.
>> If you want take your shahada in a
mosque.
>> Yeah. With my mom and my dad there.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Are they okay with it?
>> They know number 30.
>> Yeah. That's what I was going to ask.
>> That's where I am. That's where I am.
>> Could I come and let's do this, sister?
Let's do this. Let me let me give you
sister Fedria's number. This is our
sister's team who teaches how to pray
salah. Yeah.
>> I'm going to give you her number.
>> She will teach both of you
>> how to pray. Yeah. So So you know this
project that we have. Yeah. We have um
Salah instructor. We have the app. It's
called Salah Pro. Have you got Android
or Apple?
>> Apple.
>> Okay. Download. Go search Salah Pro.
Download our app. The app has like for
example um I'll show you.
>> Salah.
>> It has the Salah times. For example, you
know what time to pray. Look, it shows
me the next prayer. Uh it has the kibla
so you know the direction to pray. It
will help you find it. So you see it
helps you find the direction of kibla.
Uh there's videos tutorials on how to
pray here. You can watch it. So the app
is for free. Yeah. I'm going to give you
sister Fedria's number.
>> Yeah. That's her number.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I'm just going to take
take a picture of it. I'll just say how
it's going.
>> So get in contact with her. What we will
do is inshallah if you want we can
arrange the mosque. Contact her. What we
can do is in if you guys want we have
our studio um in East London uh you can
you can come you can do it if you want
it's up to you.
>> East London uh
>> Bin B.
>> The studio is in Bin.
>> My mom lives in both but my dad lives in
Boston.
>> No, that's fine. Do you do you want do
do you want to do it do you want to do
in a mosque or with Muslims?
>> My mom and dad there
>> specifically mosque. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. That's fine. We'll arrange that
in.
>> So what we can do is this. Yeah. You've
got Sister Fedria's number.
>> Contact her. Sister Marina.
>> Okay. Contact her. Um she will help
teach you how to pray salah. Yes. So the
salah instruction etc. If you don't mind
for example we will be we'll come with
her as well. Inshallah if you want.
Sometimes we look at like the stories
etc of people. We can film if you want.
It's totally up to you guys.
>> Come if you're not Muslim cuz yes
interest.
>> Yes. Yes. 100%.
>> Look. We're open to everybody.
>> Islam. You know what is but you know
what is Islam. You know what is Islam?
It's submission to Allah. Yeah,
>> that's all it is.
>> It's submission. It's not some kind of
lie ideology out there that submission
and you follow the path of Allah.
>> You be good.
>> Don't steal. Don't fornicate. Don't do
this. There are certain rules that you
could you could follow the sins. It's
fine as long as you repent. In Islam, we
don't believe. Look, Islam is for the
sinners. Our religion doesn't believe
that you have to be perfect. It's not
for the angels. I'm a sinner. I sin.
Yeah. I'm I'm an Islamic preacher. I
sin. Yes. But it's about acknowledging
and repenting. And when you repent, you
don't need to go to a pastor who's also
a sinner. How how you go and repenting
to a sinner who's also a sinner. We say
you go straight to God. You get and
that's what's beautiful about Islam. You
don't need to go through Jesus. You
don't need to go through prophet
Muhammad. You don't need to go through
Moses. You go straight to God. And
that's what makes Islam unique in that
way. Subhan Allah. Yeah. So you got
Sister Fuka's number. Contact her.
>> Is melody. So when I
>> Sister Melody, no problem. No problem. I
will tell her just message say brother
Ali Dawa gave you a number. Say my
friend took a shahada. I'm planning on
taking my shahada. We'll arrange the
masjid for you inshallah. And from there
onwards um like I said with the hijab
journey it's up to you guys if it's a
drink
>> I wear I wear sometimes I do
>> perfect good good look you can it's just
gradual yeah anything we say anything
you need if my family
>> okay I would say is the sister I hid it
from my family
>> they don't need to know
so yeah so so it's up to you would they
would they have would they have issues
>> are you Romanian
>> okay so um so should we should we blow
your is fine.
>> It's fine. Okay. All right. You post the
footage.
>> Alidawa Alawa and Alidaw.
>> So, this is my YouTube channel. One
second.
>> I want obviously the footage of me
taking the shahada.
>> Sure. Sure. Yeah. 100%. This is my
YouTube channel. This one.
>> We're live by the way. Look.
>> Oh my god.
>> Oh my god. That's
>> Wait, let me not say that.
>> Yeah. My name is the same also. Ali Dawa
Raw is my extra channel. I'll just show
you guys. You can also sometimes the
videos come on this channel as well.
>> Yeah. And on Instagram and Tik Tok it's
the same name. Yeah. Go on there as well
in Okay. All right. Thank you, sister.
Contact and we'll speak to you guys
soon. Thank you. And by the way,
>> have a shower
>> and you can put that prayer m in front
of you and turn to God. Yes. Okay. It's
a fresh beginning. Okay. All your sins
are forgiven inshallah. Okay. And we'll
keep you in our prayers. Thank you.
Bye-bye. Wow. That was unexpected guys.
Subhan Allah. her friend wants to accept
Islam in two months with her family but
I did not expect her the Christian woman
girl to accept Islam all very profound
cuz I was going to give her a map but I
was like oh she's a Christian she
doesn't know how to pray salah still
subhan allah Allah works in miraculous
ways Allahbar beautiful donations